رسائل تصعيد تتبادلها موسكو وكيف ميدانيا
البدايه من موسكو التي ترفع من قدراتها
الصاروخيه
الاحدث الذي ادخلته روسيا في الخدمه
نفذت وزاره الدفاع تجربه للصاروخ الذي
اصاب هدفه في البحر المتوسط بدقه عاليه
الكيلو متر تقريبا
وبحسب وزير الدفاع سريع
الاميره
فوصف الاسلحه الحديثه التي دخلت الخدمه
بانها لا مثيل لها في العالم
تمتلك مثل منظومه الصواريخ السريعه هذه
والاسلحه الحديثه الاخرى من الجيل الحديث
انا متاكد ان مثل هذه الاسلحه القويه
ستحمل روسيا بشكل وثيق من التهديدات
الخارجيه المحتمله
وفيما بدا ردا غير مباشره قال رئيس
الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه كاريل بودانوف ان
بلاده تخطط لشن هجوم كبير في الربيع
المقبل على مواقع تمركز القوات الروسيه
اما وزير الخارجيه
الاوكرانيبا فكشف عن بدء نقل انظمه
بيتريوس الامريكيه الى اوكرانيا حيث سيتم
نشرها في اقرب وقت كم قال
ثورين بتزويد اوكرانيا بانظمه باتريوت
الامريكيه لقد بدا العمل على نقل هذه
المنظمات
في اقرب وقت ممكن
حيث قالت القوات الاوكرانيه انها صدت
هجوما روسيا وتمكنك من السعاده بعض
المواقع التي فقدتها اما في بيوت الطول في
مقاطعه
فاستهدفت القوات الاوكرانيه ما قالت انه
مركز القياده العسكريه الروسيه في منطقه
ذا سيلفكا واوقعت خسائر في صفوف القوات
الروسيه